çok
[Müzik]
selam herkese bir insanın 35'lik
arkadaşının olması ne demek biliyor
musunuz öyle oluyor işte unutuyorsunuz
bazen 35'lik Arkadaşlarınızı
1987 senesinde Eylül ayında üniversiteye
ilk adım attığında gerçekten farklı bir
yere gittiğimi düşünmüştüm gerçekten
farklıydım ben başka bir ortamdan lisede
yaptığınız her şeyin takip edildiği
yapacağınız her şeyin sabahtan aileniz
tarafından Hazırlandı Her şeyin
desteklendiği bir ortamdan bir anda
bambaşka bir yere gittiniz ve çok
kontrol edemediğiniz için çok fazla
belirli çerçevede olmadığınız için
belirsizlik benim çok işime gelmişti ve
çok rahat bir üniversite hayata
geçireceğini düşünmüştüm gerçekten de
fazlaca rahat bir üniversite hayatı
geçirdim 1987 yılında başladıktan sonra
1988'de çeşitli kurumlarda part-time
çalışma çalışmalar oldum bu arada
üniversiteyi bitirmeyi unuttum ama başka
yerlerde çalışmaya başladım ve
çalışırken de çeşitli şeyler öğrendim
öğrendi bir adam bir tanesi o daha önce
bildiğim hiçbir şeyin beni daha ileriye
götürmedi olmuştu ve yeni şeyler
öğrenmek zorunda olduğumu ilk kez
üniversitede fark ettim ama hala
üniversiteyi bitirmek için oradaki
dersleri öğrenmek zorunda olduğumu fark
etmemiştim yaptığım işlerden bir tanesi
Turizm Bakanlığı'nın bir araştırmasında
istatistik okuduğum için anketlerin
yapılması için sınır kapılarına gitmek
vardı Ardahan'a gürbulakta ve Trabzon
sınır kapılarına gittim Doğubeyazıt'ta
İshak Paşa Sarayı'nda da Anket için
gittiğimde bambaşka birisiyle tanıştım
daha 17 18 yaşındayım ve tanıştığım kişi
iki metreon santim Ben bembeyaz ın o
bambaşka bir renkte ve beraber Trabzon'a
gitmeye karar verdik Çünkü o da
Türkiye'yi gezmeye gelmiş bir İngiliz de
hala da arkadaşım 35 neden daha uzun
süre neredeyse
giderken ikinci şey öğrendim Erzurum'da
Doğu Beyazıt'tan Erzurum Erzurum dan
Trabzon'a gitmek için durduğumuzda bir
aktarma yapmak için yap bir saatlik bir
zamanımız vardı ve durduğumuzda oturup
bir şeyler yerken yanımızdan geçen
gençlerden bir ters dedi ki A turistlere
bakmam Bir başka biri bembeyaz dedim
Allah Allah dedim ya tubikle bembeyaz
olacağım niye bu kadar şaşırdım ama
Türkçeyi ne güzel konuşuyor baksana dedi
Şimdi öğrendiğimiz şeyler bizi o kadar
iyi yönlendiriyor ki her şeyin onu o
çerçevede olacağına inanıyoruz 1987 ben
o üniversiteye gittikten sonra bitirmem
uzun sürsede bir şekilde bitirdim ama
bitirirken şunuda Farkettim benim
öğrenmek zorunda olduğum başka şeyler
var çünkü Yarın bugünden farklı olacak
ve yarının nasıl olacağını tahmin etme
şansımız yok Geleceği tahmin edemezsiniz
Ancak onu hazırlanabilirsiniz
hazırlanmak için okulda aldığım
eğitimlerin ya da çevremde edindiklerini
bana yetmediği kaygısıyla sivil toplum
örgütleri tanışmaya başladı ve onların
çeşitli toplantısına gitmeye başladım
Sonra 90'ların ortasında orada çeşitli
görevler almaya başladım 10 sene geçti
1997 senesi O bizim zamanımızda böyle
değildi demeye başladım çok enteresandır
sadece 10 sene geçiyor bizim zamanımız
demeye başlıyorsunuz
1997 ilk kez yurtdışına çalışmak için
gittiğimde İngiltere'ye gittiğimde
İngiltere'nin bambaşka bir yer olduğunu
ve 87d üniversite 97 Türkiye'de
çalıştığım şirketlerden İngiltere'ye
gidip çalışmaya başladım Yerin bambaşka
bir yer olduğunu görmeye başladım O
zaman şunu fark ediyorsunuz diyorsunuz
ya beni buraya getiren hiçbir şey ne
olursa olsun Eğer Bulunduğunuz yerden
hoşluk değilseniz ileriye götürecektir
ve ileriye gitmenin yöntemi de yarın
için hazır olmaktan geçiyor yani için
hazır olmadan iki tane yöntemini
2000'lerin başında tekrar Türkiye'ye
döndüğünde fark ettim bir tanesi
öğrenmeye devam edebilmek çok kolay bir
şey değil öğrenmeyi öğrenmekten söz
ediyoruz bir sürü TEDES konuşmasını bu
konuda dinleyebilirsiniz
çalışabilirsiniz kitap okuyabilirsiniz
Ama bunun temelinde bir düşünce yapısı
yer alıyor düşünce yapısı kendinizi
sürekli sorgu bu ve Konfor alanımızın
dışına çıkmak zorunluluğundan
kaynaklanıyor bunu fark ettiğinde mm
onlara gelmiştik ve bunu bana fark
ettiren şey başka bir uluslararası
deneyim olmuştu Bu sefer İngiltere Eko
sistemden çıkıp Amerika ekosistemindeki
şirketlerde çalışmaya başladığımda senin
sürekli olarak yeni şeyler öğrenip
ekibinle birlikte ilerlemeli ittirdi
Amerikan sistemi Hala da aynı o zaman
ikinci şeyi Cebime koydum bir Evet yeni
şeyler öğrenmeye devam etmek lazım ve
bunun yolu sadece Bulunduğunuz ortamda
değil farklı yerlerde olmaktan geçiyor
ikincisi farklı yerlerde olduğunuzda
sizden farklı insanlarla bir arada
olmanız gerektiği idi
2022'ye geldiğimizde hala bizim
zamanımızda diye bir sürü cümle
kurabiliyorum ve gerçekten şundan hiç
şüphe duymuyorum Yarın bugünden farklı
olacak ve Şundan da hiçbir şey
duymuyorum Yarın bugünden daha iyi
olacak bunu söylerken hepinizden şöyle
bir 20 sene öncesini düşünmenizi 50 sene
Öncesinde bir internette bu gitmenizi
150 sene öncesine bırakmanızı
isteyeceğim 150 sene önce Antibiyotikler
yaşamımıza girmeden önce insanların
ortalama ömrü sadece antibiyotiğin
yaşamınıza girdiğinde insan ömrü nereye
götürdüğünü bir bakmamıza çok büyük
ihtiyaç var ya da iki dünya savaşı ve
sonrasındaki 20-30 sene içinde bilimdeki
ilerlemenin nasıl teknolojiyle ileriye
götürdüğünü görmeye ihtiyacımız var ama
yirminci yüzyılda yaptığımız istisnasız
Her şey bizim bugüne getirdi oradan
bakmak lazım 20100 O fiziğin ve kimyanın
başat olduğu dönemlerde ve orada
yaptığımız her şey kullandığımız icat
ettiğimiz bütün patentler Biz bugüne
getirdi ama yarına götürmeyecek Çünkü mm
yedilerde mm onlarda çalıştığımız bütün
şirketlerde yaptığımız temel iş zaten
yapmak olduğu yapmakta olduğumuz işi
teknolojide daha hızlı yapmaktı ya da
daha fazla yapmak ya da daha büyük
yapmaktı Oysa bugün Eminim bu odadaki
insanla en büyük bir bölümü de ondan
muzdariptir yarın daha ile ilgili bir
şey değil yarın daha fazla ile daha
mutlu daha koştur makla daha büyük bir
ilgili bir unsur değil yarın bu odadaki
insanların beklentisi farklı bizim
teknolojiyi kullandığımız yöntem Yani
bizim zamanımızdaki yöntem soğuk savaşın
belirlediği bir dünya orta mıydı Soğuk
Savaş gelir gerilimi ile birlikte gelen
belirsizlik ve bu belirsizliğin ortaya
çıkardığı tehditlerin sonucunda bir
teknolojiyi kullanmayı belirledik ve
kullanma yöntemlerini bu şekilde koy
kurduk ama 90'lardan sonra yaklaşık bu
senelere kadar komik biraz hızlandırmış
olmakla birlikte bu 30 sene içerisinde
20 yüzyılın bütün bilimsel faaliyetlerin
sonuna getirdik öyle iyi kullandık ve
öyle Bazı yerlerde eviews ettik kötü
kullandık ki artık teknoloji bizi
Buradan daha ileriye götürecek
yaptığımız şey hep daha fazlasından
başka bir şey değil şey Yapay Zeka
zevkleri kullanmaya çalışıyoruz daha bu
tranç edebilelim diye yadam yine ulaşım
sistemlerini konuşuyoruz daha hızlı
trenler yapabilirim diye Ama hep bir
yıllardır yaptığımız aynı şeyi yapmaya
çalışıyoruz Bizi buradan sonra ileriye
götürecek şey düşünce yapısındaki önemli
değişiklik sizlerin keyifsiz hale
getiren bizim bir şekilde yaptığımız şey
benim sivil toplum örgütlerinde
çalışarak bulduğum yöntem belirsizliği
daha iyi yönetebilir hale gelmektir Ama
şu anda İçinde bulunduğumuz ortam
belirsizliği yönetme şansını tamamen
ortadan kaldırmış vaziyetim belirsizliği
yönetmeye Çalışmak yerine olası
alternatifleri masaya koyup bunlar
arasında Arzu ettiğimiz geleceği ortaya
çıkarmaya Çalışmaktan başka bir
seçeneğimiz kalmadı nasıl bir gelecek
için çalışmak istediğimizi belirleyip
bunun için bugünden çalışmaya başlamak
gerekiyor Bu amaçla gelecek
araştırmaları enstitüsü'nde 2015
yılından bu yana pek çok faaliyet
yapıyoruz uzuyor çalışmaları yapıyoruz
hayalin ettiğimiz senaryoları ilişkin
projeler bu eleştiriyoruz büyük ölçüde
uluslararası alanda ve öğrendiğimiz her
şeyi bugüne kadar beş binden fazla genç
arkadaşımızı ulaştık onları anlatıp
onların gelecek hayaline ilişkin tekrar
Uz görüleri güncellemeyi özen
gösteriyoruz elbise ve altındaki 5000
çocuklar onları gelecek hayalini görüp
bütün ilerlemelerin Uz göğsüne nasıl
oradan besleyebiliriz diye çalışmaya
devam ediyoruz ama yaptığımız şey hala
geleceği tasarlamak oraya ulaşmak için
aksiyona ihtiyaç var çünkü geleceği
tasarlayanlar değil yapanlar ortaya
çıkarıyor ve bu odadan Eğer tasarlayıp
onun peşinde koşmaya başlayan lar
çıkmazsa yan odadan çıkacaklar onların
tasarladığı ve ortaya çıkardığı
geleceğin içerisinde olacağız şimdi bizi
20 yüzyılın bilimini oradaki patentlerin
ve gelişimleri inovasyonu o kadar iyi
kullandık ve 2020 lira geldik ki
doksanlarla 2020 arasındaki gerçekten
bir refah döneminin sonrasında
Önümüzdeki on O senin çok iyi geçmesini
beklemiyoruz iki açıdan iyi geçmeyecek
Bir tanesi ekonomik
belirsizlikte sadece Türkiye'de değil
bütün dünyada ya etkili bir yönlendirici
olacak Bu ekonomik belirsizliğin temel
nedenim kaynaklara sahip olabilmek ama
bilgiye de sahip olabilmek bu bilgi
bizim 20 yüzyılda geliştirdiğimiz bilgi
değil Şu anda geldikten sonra
ihtiyacımız olan bir örneğin yapay
zekayı daha iyi bir daha iyi ilaç
yönetmek için kullanıyoruz ya da 2040
yılındaki beklentilerden bir tanesi
kanserin şeker hastalığı gibi
yönetilebilir bir hastalık haline
gelmesi için yatırımlar yapıyoruz ama
aynı yapay zekanın
insanın kendisine verdiği vereceği olası
bir zararı Örneğin sigara içiyor
olmasını engellemek konusunda neler
yapabileceğinden Emin değiliz burada
tedirginlik hep robotların elimizden işi
alması ya da yapay zekanın yada benzeri
teknolojileri bizim için karar verebilir
duruma gelmesi
bu ama hep hedefli teknoloji varmış gibi
görüyoruz ama hedefe teknoloji o hedefe
o teknolojiyi kullanacak kapasite var
kim kullanacaksa kim geliştirecek s
kararlı o verecek teknoloji çünkü sizin
yönlendirdiğimiz şekilde ileriye gidiyor
2022 lerden mm 40'a baktığımız zaman bu
odadaki çoğu arkadaşımızın
doğum tarihine göre 2040 çok daha yakın
bir tarih sadece 18 Sn var ya da 17
buçuk sene kaldım yerde olduğumuzdan
bugüne kadar geçirdiğiniz zamandan daha
kısa bir süre sonra mm kırkın içinde
olacaksınız Ben aynı şeyi kendim de 2070
için söylüyorum 2070 benim doğduğu
tarihten daha yakın bana artıp mm kırkın
nasıl olacağını çok fazla hayal etmenizi
ihtiyacınız olmayabilir çünkü başka
birisi onu hayal ediyor ve oraya doğru
Sizi çekecek Ama şunu lütfen unutmayın
yirminci yüzyılda sizler gibi bilimin
içerisinde olan insanların yaptıkları
bizi buraya getirdi
Bu 21. yüzyılda sizlerin yapacakları şey
22 yüzyılda oluşturacak 22 yüzyılın
nasıl bir Yüzyıl olacağının sizlerin
ortaya çıkaracağı değişiklikler ya da bu
kanal bu konuda yapacağınız çalışmalar
gerçekleştirecek en başta söyledim ya
belirsizlik 87 üniversiteye gittiğimde
de İçine düştüğüm gel kozadan Çıkmak
gibi Aslında sürekli olarak çıktığımızda
bir sonraki adıma sürekli olarak
Kendimizi geliştirmek zorunda kaldığımız
bir dönem Bundan sonra bu nedenle
Öğrenmeyi Öğrenmek çok kritik
unsurlardan bir tanesi ama 2040/1
2050'ye doğru giderken göz önünde
bulundurmamız gereken unsurlardan Birisi
Evet kendimiz kendimiziz ve burayı
kendimizi hazırlamamız gerekiyor ama
ikincisi bizim kontrolümüzde olmayan
faktörler var Bunlardan en önemlisi
iklim değişikliği iklimin yaşamı
ekonomiyi ve sosyal toplumları nasıl
değiştirebileceği konusunda büyük bir
Risk ve belirsizlik var bu
belirsizlikler asla bitmeyecek bu
edeceğimiz konusundan çok o
belirsizliğin içerisine nasıl ileri
gideceğimizi çözmemiz gerekecek ikincisi
iklim krizinden sonra çok ciddi bir göç
ve şehirleşme dalgası şu anda yaşıyoruz
ama bu gittikçe artan bir sorun haline
gelecek sadece geçen sene 81 milyon kişi
dünyada isteğinin dışında yer değiştirdi
bu dünyada iklim değişikliği ile
birlikte daha da büyük bir rakam haline
gelecek şimdi bunların hepsi cebimize
durması gereken sorunlar üçüncüsü
ekonomik belirsizlik var işte 2-3 sene
kobiden hemen önceki sene ortaya çıkan
Amerika ile Çin arasındaki ekonomik
savaşı
bugün çift krizim ya da konteyner prizi
olarak da bakabilirsiniz ekonomiyi kimin
daha iyi yönetebileceği konusu
Önümüzdeki 20 seneye damgasını vuracak
şeylerden bir tanesi ve bu olay için çok
büyük bir fırsat var 1750 lerden biri
Batı eksende ekonomik ağırlık Ve
gittikçe doğru o kayıyor ve bu doğuya
kayışını içerisinde ise bu dönüyor E7
ülkeleri deniyor Türkiye'de onlardan bir
tanesi edinin olduğu 2040 senesini doğru
gittikçe artacak en tipik örneği şu
1995'te G7 ülkeleri ile E7 ülkelerini
karşılaştırdığınızda Ticaret hacimleri
G7 nin yarısı kadardı E7 ülkelerinin
Bugün hemen hemen eşit 2040 yılında E7
ülkelerinin toplam ticaret hacmi j7'nin
iki katı olacak
ekonomik ağırlığın kaydı bir eksende
bütün politik ve sosyolojik ağırlığında
kayıyor olması kaçınılmaz 1750 lerdeki
endüstri devriminin şu anda kendisi
devrimine yansıması o zamanlar ortaya
çıkan asgari ücret yada benzeri
uygulamaların bugün konuşulduğu benzer
uygulamalara doğru kayıyor olmasına
bakın o zaman asgari ücret çıktığı 8
saat çalışır 8 saat eğlenir 8 saat uyur
kavramı çıktı eğlenmesini en yeni
sektörler ortaya çıktı Bugün 8 saatte
çalışmaz ama o parayı veren vermeliyiz
ki parayı harcayabilirsiniz şirketler
ilerletme bilsinler teknoloji noktasına
geldi
mi ileriye doğru baktığınızda da göçten
sonra dördüncü
temel konu ekonomiden sonra dördüncü
temel konum gerçekten yaşlanan toplum
gidiyorum ya 2070w doğduğu tarihten daha
yakınım diye 2050 yılında dünyada 60
yaşını geçen insanların sayısı Beş
yaşındaki beş yaşın altındakilerin
sayısından çok daha fazla olacak iki
katı kadar e bekleniyor bu çok önemli
bir değişim ve bu değişimin
farklı kılan ve sizin göz önünde
bulundurmanız kaçınılmaz olan konulardan
bir tanesi o tarih geldiğinde
dünyadaki toplam sermayenin yaklaşık
yüzde yetmiş 273 60 yaşın üzerindekiler
de olacak Enpara 10 mı Ama gelecek sizin
elinizde bunun arasındaki denge en zor
olan yoksa insanlık bugüne kadar pek çok
katastrofik olayın üstesinden
geldim Şu anda iklim krizinin üstesinden
gelecek konusunda herhangi bir soru
işareti mi Yok bir sürü a b c planımız
var uzaya gitmekten tuttuğumda genetik
araştırmaları kadar farklı yerlere doğru
gidiyor Ama insanların birbirleri
arasındaki ilişkiyi yönetebilme nin
dengesini kurmak çok kolay olmayacak
bunu yaparken sivil toplumun bana
öğrettiği iki tane şey var Bir tanesi
Çevrenizdeki beş kişinin ortalaması
olduğunuz kimlerle zaman geçiriyorsanız
bir çevrenize bakın onlara benziyorsunuz
insan diğerinin aynısı Çünkü
hangi beş kişiyle birlikte iseniz
geleceği oluştururken sizin o Kupası
tenis o beş kişiyle birlikte
oluşturuluyor İkincisi o beş kişiyi
seçmenin dışında ikincisi sivil toplum
örgütlerinin bana verdiği şey Konfor
alanımın dışına çıkmaktı Yapmak
istemediğim ya da yap şu anda olduğum
şeyleri yapmak konusunda sivil toplum
örgütlerinde çok şey öğrendim ama şu
anda gelecek araştırmaları enstitüsü'nde
en çok keyif olarak yaptığımız şey bir
yapmak zorunda olduğumuz işler var
hepimizin profesyonel bir hayatı var ve
bu bütün ömrümüz boyunca yaşamın gerçeği
içinde gerçeği olacak Size içinde yapmak
zorunda olduğumuz işler var faturalı
ödeyeceksiniz Ailenizde öyle
geçireceksiniz yapmak istediğiniz şeyler
öyle gideceksiniz yurtdışına ya
çocuklarınızı o yöntemle okuyacaksınız
Bir de yapmak istedikleriniz var
gerçekten doğru olduğuna inandığınız
merak ettiğiniz sizden daha akıllı
insanlarla Daha yaratıcı insanlarla Daha
çalışkan insanlarla daha farklı düşünen
insanlar yapmak istediğiniz şeyler var
Bunu yapmanın tek yeri sivil toplum
örgütleri birincisi gerçekten Konfor
alanı dışına çıkmak ikincisi birlikte
çalışabilmek üçüncüsü de multidisipliner
bakabilmek farklı disiplinlerden farklı
düşünenler ve farklı şekilde bakabilen
lerden bir araya gelmek şimdi gelecek
konusunda en
ben
onu nasıl yöneteceğim iz değil ona nasıl
hazırlanacağız oldu çünkü geleceği
yönetmek ya da herhangi bir şey yönetmek
çok kolay değil artık ama ona hazır
olmak için bu üç tane şeyi unutmamak
lazım Charles Dickens İki Şehrin
Hikayesi de harika söylüyor başlarken
yok ki en güzel zamanlardı mı en kötü
zamanlardır Roman böyle başlıyor
1800'lerin başında yani Sümer tabletleri
okuduğunuzda benzer sorunlar
görüyorsunuz şehrin bir tarafı gerçekten
çok gelire sahip başka bir tarafın
sulama olmadığı için İyi gelirsen yüz
sene sonra da benzer sorunlar olacak
nasıl bugün 800 milyon kişi hala yatağa
aç gidiyorsa 2040 da 2050'de de aynı
sorunlar olacak ama bunun daha Adil hale
gelmesini sağlamak sizin elinizde Çünkü
siz yapmazsanız mutlaka başka birisi
Yapacak çok teşekkür ederim